hey guys my name is Jess today's is the
second of much and you're watching games
buttons
that's up today uncharted 4 has been
officially delayed for a third time the
president and CEO of sony computer
entertainment america sean laden worked
on the PlayStation Blog in an effort to
meet the considerable worldwide demand
and to ensure that all gamers worldwide
have the opportunity to play the game on
day one we have chosen to postpone the
launch of the game by two weeks to allow
for extra manufacturing time the game
will now be released on May 10 Laden
added that while they understand the
extra weight isn't I'm deal the game is
quote phenomenal despite the delay this
weekend's open beta stress test for
uncharted force multiplayer mode is
still going ahead Microsoft has
announced the next force' game and it's
headlining car the company has confirmed
that the Lamborghini Centenario which
isn't even available yet will be the
cover car for the next game on an xbox
wire post the publisher added we're not
quite ready to unveil the title or any
big details on the next warts again yet
you'll have to wait for our xbox media
briefing at june's 2016 III for that
they added that the game will have the
largest and most diverse car list of any
video game franchise of this generation
Microsoft have also released a teaser
trailer which you can check out in a
story on gamespot finally EA seem to
have suggested that Mass Effect
Andromeda won't be arriving until 2017
during a business summit interview eh
chief financial officer Blake Jorgensen
appeared to insinuate that the next Mass
Effect would launch during the fiscal
fourth quarter and not the calendar
fourth quarter if that is the case that
would put the game's release sometime
within the first three months of 2017 up
until now EA have said that Mass Effect
Andromeda will come out during holiday
2016 gamespot have contact
EA for clarification let me know down in
that comment section how you feel about
today's Mass Effect and uncharted news
you can also head to gain spot where
we've got stories on the division and
ps4 TV that is everything I have for you
today as always let me know what matter
to you and I will get to again tomorrow